[Musik]
Zeit mitbringen muss wer seinen
Lebenslauf mit seinen beruflichen
Stationen und die Liste seiner
wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten auch nur
einigermaßen gründlich durchlesen will
vom intensiven Studium ganz zu schweigen
da befällt einen Moderator gerade zu
Trübsinn wenn er nur 30 Minuten Zeit hat
Personen und Werk vorzustellen wir tun
es trotzdem herzlich willkommen bei
Phoenix persönlich Professor Herfried
Münkler Politikwissenschaftler bekannt
nicht nur für seine große Schaffens
sondern auch für seine ausgeprägte
diskursfreude
lassen Sie uns gleich rein ins Geschehen
gehen wird der Begriff Zeitenwende zu
inflationär gebraucht
zeitenwände ist ein schwieriger Begriff
nicht weil man sozusagen unter Wände
eine langsame sich über Monate wenn ich
Jahre hinziehende Veränderungen sich
vorstellen kann aber auch ein auf der
Stelle sich vollziehen Newton und die
politische Auseinandersetzung um den
Begriff läuft gewissermaßen um die Frage
wie energisch diese Wände sein soll den
einen SC zu komoot den anderen zu abrupt
und das sind die Auseinandersetzungen
und das führt natürlich dazu dass
permanent der Begriff apostrophiert wird
was steht eigentlich da alles auf dem
Spiel die kulturelle und wirtschaftliche
Hegemonie des Westens ein
wohlstandsversprechen das bisher nahezu
abschlagsfrei eingelöst worden ist die
Demokratie als Selbstläufer
naja zunächst einmal wenn wir es allein
auf uns beziehen also vielleicht auf
Deutschland oder auf Europa dann kann
man sagen es findet eine umgewichtung im
Bereich der machtorten statt wir haben
relativ lange darauf gesetzt dass
wirtschaftlicher Macht das
Steuerungsmittel auch der
internationalen Politik ist und dass sie
gewissermaßen an die Stelle von
militärischer Macht tritt Verbund mit
vielleicht kultureller macht und das
beides zusammen politische Macht
konstituiert das ist so jetzt nicht mehr
militärische Macht hat an Bedeutung wie
der deutlich geworden
schauen wir kurz auf ihre Biografie 1951
in Hessen auf die Welt gekommen nach dem
Abitur Studium von Germanistik
Politikwissenschaft und Philosophie
promoviert haben sie zu Nicole majaelli
die Situation gilt heute als
Standardwerk über den großen Florentina
sie waren auch Mitglied der Jungs
Sozialisten sind heute noch Mitglied der
SPD wenn ich das jetzt auf der Zeit
Schiene mal so ein bisschen nachrechne
muss das ja so um das Jahr 1968
vielleicht auch ein bisschen später
gewesen sind dass sie JUSO waren waren
sie eigentlich ein revoluter
ja ich weiß nicht ob ich das selber von
mir sagen würde vermutlich eher nicht
aber
das konservative
Friedberger Kleinbürgertum hätte mich
vermutlich als einen solchen gesehen das
denke ich schon ja
ich bin freilich erst 1970 also nach dem
Abitur in eine Partei in die SPD
eingetreten das gehört aber noch zu 68%
die 68er
Auseinandersetzungen Notstandsgesetze
und vieles andere mehr hat natürlich die
politische sozialisationen in homerase
geprägt ja gibt es noch etwas anderes
was ich geprägt hat gerade jetzt auch im
Hinblick auf ihre spätere
wissenschaftliche Arbeit
ja vielleicht und sagen ich komme aus
einer Lehrer Familie der Umstand dass
sozusagen da
Schreibtische gab bei denen man saß oder
erwartet wurde dass man da saß
Schularbeiten macht
das hat sich ja ein Einfluss auf mich
und meine Lebensführung gehabt
und schon gewissen Unterbrechungen in
denen ich ja sozusagen spät aufgestanden
bin und auch spät ins Bett gegangen bin
habe ich aber wieder dann sozusagen mich
zurückbewegt in eher disziplinierte
Lebensführung
werden manche Eltern wahrscheinlich
neidisch auf ihre Eltern schauen wenn
sie da so sagen ein Thema zieht sich ja
durch ihre publizistische
wissenschaftliche Arbeit wie ein roter
Faden der Krieg der 30-jährige Krieg der
Erste Weltkrieg das sind inzwischen auch
Standardwerke die sie dazu verfasst
haben das waren ja zwei
menschheitskatastrophen die deutsche
Geschichte bis zum heutigen Tag prägen
hat Herr Heraklit aus ephesusrecht das
der Krieg der Vater allerdings ist er
vielleicht nicht der Vater aller Dinge
aber doch
in bestimmten historischen Etappen mehr
in anderen weniger prägend für den
Fortgang der Dinge für unseren
Erfahrungsraum oder auch unseren
Erwartungshorizont und ich gehör nun mal
mit einem 50 1951 geboren zu der
Generation
für die eigentlich der Krieg etwas in
der Vergangenheit liegendes wahr was
natürlich sozusagen
für meine Eltern noch eine prägende
Rolle gespielt hat aber verbunden mit
der Erwartung
nie wieder nicht oder sagen das ist
abgeschlossene Vergangenheit ich habe
dafür auch sozusagen für diese
Einstellung den Begriff der
prostaurischen Gesellschaft geprägt das
heißt nicht dass wir eine unheurische
Gesellschaft sind aber das wir eine sind
die zurückschaut auf Zeiten in denen
gewissermaßen die Zumutung des
heroischen des selbstopfers zentral
gewesen ist das wird glaube ich bei
allen Veränderungen die sich jetzt
abgespielt haben so nicht mehr sein es
bleibt dabei wir sind eine postherische
Gesellschaft und manche Hinsicht kann
man ja auch mit Interesse beobachten
auch die russische Gesellschaft ist das
sonst hättet ihr nicht diese
mobilisierungsprobleme
bleiben wir noch einen Moment bei ihrer
Vergangenheit
1970 haben sie gesagt sind sie der SPD
dann beigetreten ich vermute mal
mutmaßlich auch wegen des damaligen
spd-parteivorsitzenden Bundeskanzlerin
Brand der den Satz von Heraklit ja
umgedreht hat der hat gesagt nicht der
Krieg sondern der Frieden ist der Vater
allerdings
naja für einen Politiker der sagt ja
manche Dinge die eher als Botschaft also
performativ zu verstehen sind als dass
er damit etwas sagen will wovon er
unbedingt überzeugt ist dass das der
Fall sei nicht manche Äußerungen von
Politikern sind eher in dem Sinne es
soll so sein und im Sinne von es soll so
sein bin ich dadurch aus bei Willy
Brandt
ich glaube allerdings dass in der
Vergangenheit jedenfalls
Kriege die großen Veränderungen von
Konstellationen von Machtkonstellationen
gewesen sind aber auch von sozialen
Konstellationen ist sehr interessant
dass jemand ein Buch schreiben konnte
und unter dem Titel nach dem Krieg sind
wir alle gleich das heißt zwar jetzt
nicht wirklich dass wir alle gleich sind
aber wir sind gleicher als wir vor dem
Krieg waren
also sagen wenn
soziales Gefälle abgebaut oder in Frage
gestellt wird dann spielt der Krieg eine
nicht unerhebliche Rolle das kann man
gerade in Europa in Deutschland an den
Folgen des Ersten Weltkrieges sehen
sowohl was die Veränderung oder das
Anheben des steuerstaates
anbetrifft als auch die Veränderung der
Sozialversicherungssysteme
einfach um auf die vielen einfachen
Soldaten die als aus diesem
Krieg wurde jedenfalls
beschädigt und geschädigt zurückgekommen
sind für die zu sorgen im Sinne der
kollektiven Verantwortung das ist etwas
was vielleicht auch irgendwann ohne
diesen Krieg stattgefunden hat aber das
ist in dieser Intensität und
umfanglichkeit stattgefunden hat hat mit
dem Ersten Weltkrieg so das heißt also
da hat der Krieg quasi soziale Unwuchten
auch beseitigt genau das könnte man von
dem aktuellen Krieg mit dem wir uns
jetzt gerade beschäftigen nach dem
Überfall auf die Ukraine könnte das eine
mögliche ähnliche Folge haben dann nicht
für Deutschland nur sondern für Europa
ja also sicher wird diese
Auseinandersetzung von der wir gar nicht
wissen wann sie zu Ende sein wird oder
ob sie noch weiter eskaliert oder ob sie
nur fort wählt also sozusagen unterhalb
eines Waffen Stillstandes aber es ist
ein permanenter Anspannung bleibt
was mir wahrscheinlich zu sein scheint
wird man davon sagen können sie hat auf
die Europäer erhebliche Rückwirkungen
insofern wir den Höhepunkt unseres
Wohlstandes vorerst überschritten haben
werden aufgrund der Entkoppelung des
russischen Wirtschaftskreislaufs des
europäischen Wirtschaftskreislaufs aber
auch aufgrund des Umstandes dass höhere
Ausgaben für ja letzten Endes
unproduktive Ergebnisse nämlich die
Fähigkeit zur Landes und
bündnisverteidigung getätigt werden
müssen
das denke ich steht außer Frage dass das
der Fall ist und insofern wird das bei
uns einiges verändern aber die Crew der
Kruse Eingriff dieses Krieges in den
Fortgang der Geschichte ist er hat die
Ukraine zu einer wirklichen Nation
gemacht nicht sozusagen innere
Trennlinien die es ja vorher durchaus
gab die man beobachten konnte sind
gewissermaßen unter dem Druck der
Feindschaft des Angriffs der Brutalität
verschwunden spielen keine Rolle mehr
und er hat unseren Blick auch für
geopolitische Konstellation war ja
relativ lange in Deutschland verpönt
überhaupt diesen Begriff zu gebrauchen
für geopolitische Konstellationen
geschärft oder jedenfalls die
Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelenkt sondern
mit den Einsatz der Bundeswehr war es ja
auch lange Zeit verpönt von Krieg zu
sprechen zum Beispiel in Afghanistan das
sind vielleicht noch mal auf die
Reaktionen auf diesen Krieg in
Deutschland eingehen da gibt es ja auch
großen dezents wie man darauf reagiert
wir hatten gerade von Willy Brandt ja
schon gesprochen die Pazifisten unter
den heutigen Sozialdemokraten die
berufen sich ja auf für die Brand wenn
sie gegen Waffenlieferungen sind an die
Ukraine ist das ein großes
Missverständnis
ja ich glaube es gibt inzwischen nachdem
auch Herr Mütze nicht sozusagen sein
Damaskus Erlebnis gehabt hat in der
Sozialdemokratie nicht mehr sehr viele
die sagen
ich bin Pazifist ich bin Gegenwart von
Lieferungen
das scheint sich verändert zu haben das
sind eher Leute die entweder auf der
politischen Rechten oder ganz auf der
linken stehen
und bei denen es gibt sein großes
Missverständnis nicht Pazifismus ist
zunächst einmal eine persönliche
Entscheidung die ich nur für mich und
ausschließlich für mich treffen kann die
Folgen von Gewalt zu ertragen und sie
nicht mit Gegengewalt zu beantworten und
sobald man das versucht politisch zu
machen muss man überlegen worüber redet
man nicht ich kann ja sozusagen nicht
einem anderen vorschreiben dass er sich
nicht wehrt wenn er angegriffen wird nur
weil ich mich nicht während will
das heißt sozusagen man muss
unterscheiden zwischen Angriffskrieg und
Verteidigungskrieg und dort wo der
Pazifismus als ethischer Einstellung
politisch beworben ist das und nach dem
Ersten Weltkrieg teilweise schon vorher
aber vor allen Dingen nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg ist fundamental ist
Unterscheidung zwischen Angriffskrieg
und Verteidigungskrieg und da gibt es ja
gar keine Frage
wer der Angreifer ist Russland und wer
der Verteidiger ist die Ukraine und von
daher ist es
zynisch gewissermaßen der ihnen
Ukrainern zu glauben man könnte man
solle man müsste ihnen die Waffen aus
der Hand nehmen um sie wehrlos zu machen
und sich einem
naja
einem Angreifer auszuliefern bei dem man
nicht sicher sein kann dass er
Wehrlosigkeit nicht zu neuen
Gewaltexzessen nutzt Butcher und andere
Art das sind ja dafür ein Symbol ja
gerade gesagt dass der der Begriff
Pazifismus
missverstanden sein könnte würde denn
auch gezielt missbraucht im Moment
naja in dem Sinne das gewässermaßen die
Vorstellung wir sind für Frieden oder
Manifest für Frieden
genau konkretisiert dahingehend dass man
den angegriffenen und ohnehin
schwächeren auch noch weiter schwächen
aber sagt ja wir geben dem aber keine
Waffen mehr das ist glaube ich ein
Missbrauch des Begriffs Friedens auch
wenn man alle Forderungen letzten Endes
an die Ukraine und zalensky adressiert
und Putin außen vor lässt mit dem
politisch vielleicht nachvollziehbaren
Argumenten aber bei dem können wir ja
sowieso nichts bewirken nicht aber wenn
man dieses Argument für sich geltend
macht dann muss man auch im Hinblick auf
die anderen die Klappe halten
der die Deutschen haben ja sowieso eine
spezielle Haltung zum Krieg haben oder
hatten aus den bekannten historischen
Gründen ist diese Haltung inzwischen
fragwürdig
auch nein ich meine dass man
energisch gegen Angriffskriege ist gegen
den Gebrauch militärischer Wald Gewalt
zur Durchsetzung politischer Zwecke und
Ziele das glaube ich ist nach wie vor
nachvollziehbar und müssen die Deutschen
auch mal überlegen
und das wenn sie sagen okay wir haben
dieses Problem mit dem Hitler und den
konservativen erlebten ab dem Anschluss
Österreichs in eine Politik der
gewaltsamen Bedrohung der anderen
eingetreten zu sein
dass vielleicht vermutlich Frau
Wagenknecht und Frau Schwarzer auf der
anderen Seite stehen nicht und in
Tschechen sagen ja okay ihr Kapitel
gegen die Wehrmacht sowieso keine Chance
also gibt er nicht was die Tschechien
auch tun
und aber auch vielleicht bei dem Polen
nicht ähm mit dem Argument nein dann
wäre aber der weltkriegt nicht am ersten
99 ausgebrochen das ist vermutlich auch
so klausewitz sagt wenn in diesem
Zusammenhang der Krieg beginnt nicht mit
dem Angriff sondern mit der Verteidigung
weil der Angriff das Besetzen zum
absoluten Zweck hat die Verteidigung
aber das Kämpfen das ist wahr das muss
man sich sozusagen zunächst noch mal
vielleicht was sagen philosophisch vor
Augen führen um mich dem unmittelbaren
Eindruck des gewaltgeschehens aber jetzt
nach Mut und anderes zu erliegen sondern
analytisch zu begreifen mit welchen
Konstellationen man es zu tun hat also
ich glaube sozusagen eine kluge
Betrachtung der deutschen Geschichte
endet mit hoher Zwangsläufigkeit
dabei dass man sagt ja wir müssen uns
jetzt wieder um unsere Fähigkeit der
Landes- und bündnisverteidigung kümmern
es gilt nicht mehr der Satz von Helmut
Kohl wir sind umzingelt von Freunden
sondern es ist schwieriger geworden und
wir müssen auf jeden Fall den
unterstützen der sich an einer
tendenziell verzweifelten Situation
befindet
muss in unsere Haltung jetzt tatsächlich
neu ausgerichtet werden könnte auch
sagen es hat ja diese Häutung die sie da
angesprochen haben ja tatsächlich in den
letzten Jahren durchaus Stadt gefunden
diese diese Einstellung zum Krieg diese
Unterstützung von einer Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung bei uns für die denn bleiben
ja ich glaube schon die hat sich jetzt
über ein Jahr lang entwickelt und ist
auch relativ stabil sehe jetzt nicht
dass diese ohne weiteres kippt dann
würde gern dazu noch sagen nicht es gibt
sozusagen Sätze die unabhängig von dem
Ort und dem Zeitpunkt an dem sie
geäußert werden gelten und gelten sollen
das können ethische Formeln sein die ich
für mich aufstelle den ich mich
verpflichtet fühle das können allgemeine
Aussagen sein aber sobald das ganze in
das Feld der Politik eintritt oder dem
es politische Sätze wird es sehr viel
abhängig von Ort und Zeit und den
Umständen und das muss man dann auch
entsprechend
anpassen können also
das ganze hat ja seinen Vorlauf bei der
Betrachtung der jugoslawischen Zerfalls
Kriege als ich denke Joschka Fischer die
Formel nie wieder Krieg durch die nie
wieder ausschwitzt ersetzt hat
das war schon eine tiefgreifende
Veränderung die aber zu tun hatte damit
dass wir eben nicht mehr in einer
Situation der aus Ost-West-Konflikt das
nicht und den gefriergefrosteten
Konstellationen zu tun hatten sondern
dass ich hier ein Gebilde Jugoslawien
dass jedenfalls in der Tito Zeit ein
Ergebnis der Konfrontation von Ost und
West als Pufferstaat dazwischen gewesen
ist aufzulösen begann und vor der Frage
stand wo wollen wir eigentlich dazu
gehören und wie wollen wir dazu gehören
ganz kurz auf die Ukraine und blicken
was den Krieg angeht in welcher Phase
ist der gerade und sind
Verhandlungen
in absehbarer Zeit denkbar
Waffenstillstandsverhandlungen
zumindestens
Waffenstillstandsverhandlungen sind
immer denkbar die Frage ist nur mit
welcher Aussicht auf Erfolg und unter
welchen Bedingungen und
Augenblick sind die Ziele der beiden
Krieg führenden Parteien Defensive Ziele
der Ukraine nämlich gewissermaßen die
Wiederherstellung der Grenzen entweder
vor 2014 oder vor dem 24 Februar 22 auf
der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite
so weit man dem Kreml und seinen
Verlautbarungen trauen darf
die Vorstellung der russischen Führung
die Ukraine muss verschwinden und zwar
nicht deswegen weil sie mögliches
Aufmarschgebiet der NATO wäre das ist ja
Unfug sondern weil es ein alternatives
Russland sein könnte mit höherem
Wohlstand und obendrein auch noch Wahlen
die als Wahlen einigermaßen
funktionieren und einer sich
doch allmählich gegen das gegen die
Korruption durchsetzen und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit langsam und mühselig
und ich bin der letzte der die Ukraine
in ihrem gegenwärtigen Zustand
idealisieren will
aber sozusagen was man im Kreml fürchtet
ist ein Maidan auf dem Roten Platz nicht
und sozusagen es muss deutlich gemacht
werden dass in allen diesen Räumen gilt
Oppositionen gibt es nicht und wo sie
sich dennoch berührt da wird sie in
Lager gesteckt nicht
gewissermaßen das was Putin im Falle
Belarus mit Lukaschenko ja durchgesetzt
hat das ging in der Ukraine nicht
aufgrund zweimal mai daran Orangen
Revolution und eure meinte an
und
deswegen denke ich wird das noch eine
Zeit lang so sein jetzt war das großes
Thema ist ja das Thema Demokratie
neuestes Buch das veröffentlicht wurde
heißt ja Zukunft der Demokratie jetzt
weiß er offensichtlich ein Irrtum 1989
mit dem Niedergang des Sowjet in
Imperiums zu glauben dass ich Demokratie
durchgesetzt hat sozusagen weltweit
heute gibt es glaube ich wieder mehr
Autokratien als Demokratien zumindestens
ist das so festgestellt und nachgezählt
worden aus dieser fundamentalen
historischen viel Einschätzung eine
besondere Gefahr jetzt für die liberalen
Demokratien
ja sie haben sozusagen sich ein bisschen
bequem gemacht sie haben sich sozusagen
geschichtsphilosophisch auf der
Siegerstraße gewähmt oder man kann auch
sagen sie haben die Konstellation des
Augenblicks für in Beton gegossene
Zukunft gehalten
ich würde mich jetzt nicht aufs hohe
Rost setzen wollen und sagen dass es ein
Exzess von Naivität oder der Leimer
geworden soll man kann schon verstehen
nachvollziehen warum nach der
Stresssituation des Kalten Krieges den
80er Jahren mit den Auseinandersetzungen
Nachrüstung oder Vorrüstung oder was
auch immer
das eine ungeheure Erleichterung war und
man hat ja sozusagen die Bipolarität der
aus westkonferenz schon eher sagen für
eine
Unordnung gehalten als für ein
Ordnungssystem und wenn man das so getan
hat aber gedacht hat hat man sozusagen
nicht verstanden dass die
Herausforderungen einer nicht mehr
bipolar geordneten Welt eigentlich
dramatisch sein werden nicht da kam halt
Fukuyama und andere und haben diese
Geschichte erzählt genau
diese Geschichte erzählt dass der Weg in
Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft
alternativlos sei der hätte man
allerdings schon der Betrachtung des
Frühjahrs 89
Platz das Himmlischen Friedens in Peking
so seine Zweifel haben können und die
Zweifler sind halt jetzt bestätigt
das machen wir im Umgang mit China weil
es jetzt auch China angesprochen haben
möglicherweise den gleichen Fehler wie
im Umgang mit Russland dass wir uns in
eine auch aus nachvollziehbaren
rationalen Gründen in eine ökonomische
Abhängigkeit gegeben die uns auch mal
leid tun wird
das würde ich sagen ist eine der
schwierigen Fragen nicht meine die
Herstellung von Abhängigkeiten
beiderseitigen Abhängigkeiten ist ja
eigentlich eines Strategie der Sicherung
einer Friedensordnung und je größer die
Abhängigkeiten
wechselseitig sind desto stärker kann
man auch sagen ist im Prinzip die
Grundlage des Vertrauens die die eine
Seite zur anderen umgekehrt hat
das
gilt in vieler Hinsicht auch heute noch
wenn das Problem ist
die Voraussetzungen nämlich dass man nur
rationale Akteure in der Politik hat die
im Prinzip nach dem Modell des
homoökonomikus das rationalen abweges
von Nutzen und Kosten sind dann kann
sich gut vorstellen dass macron und Frau
bärbock und wer da alles
im Januar und frühen Februar 22 nach
Moskau geflogen ist und da unten in
diesem eigentümmlichen Tisch
saßen
das eigentlich wenn er diesen Angriff
beginnt er davon
vor allen Dingen Nachteile haben wird
Entkoppelung der Wirtschaftskreisläufe
und derleier
sie haben halt nicht realisiert dass
Putin offenbar sehr viel stärker auf ein
historisches Resort
nämlich wir waren mal wer und wir sind
jetzt niemand mehr und wir wollen wieder
mehr werden
dann glaube ich allerdings dass die
Deutschen wenn sie mit ihrer Geschichte
ein bisschen klüger umgehen würden ganz
gut herausbekommen könnten wie sowas
funktioniert denn nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg war sei und so weiter weil sie
auch voll reson Thema und das reser und
immer weil die Ressourcen die die
Konservativen die Rechten und die Nazis
bewirtschaftet haben das Resultat
teilweise auch noch
bisschen die 60er Jahre hinein in der
Bundesrepublik zu spüren und dann
allerdings ist es durch Wohlstand
verschwunden und irgendwann waren aber
was weiß ich die Vertriebenen Verbände
nur noch Folklore
die Erwartung war
dieses Modell das ja auch in der EWG und
EG dann funktioniert hat weiten wir aus
der Erweiterung der EU war eigentlich
dem verpflichtet denn die Staaten dort
im Osten haben in den 1920er Jahren
einige Hefte gekriege gegeneinander
geführt nicht so Wohlstand und das
wollte man auch mit den Russen machen ne
das hat halt nicht funktioniert das
heißt sozusagen man sollte dieses Modell
nicht ganz wegschmeißen aber man muss es
klüger und vorsichtiger benutzen als es
in der Vergangenheit benutzt war das ist
zum Schluss der Sendung nochmal auf
Demokratie kommen auch auf die Zukunft
der Demokratie sie haben vorhin gesagt
wir haben uns da ein bisschen bequem
drin gemacht in der Demokratie
gleichzeitig bröckelt der Wohlstand der
diese Demokratien in den letzten
Jahrzehnten Jahr eng zusammengefügt hat
wie kann man diese Bequemlichkeit
überwinden es gibt ja sicherlich viele
Menschen die sagen also mir ist wichtig
Fußball Male Auto fahren aber um die
anderen Dinge kümmert sich jemand anders
ja das ist eine der Gefahren der
Demokratie dass man sie beschreibt
gewissermaßen nachdem
Modelle eines Supermarkts nicht man geht
rein und sucht sich irgendwas aus was
man will also in der Partei und die
kreuzt man dann an und wenn man
zufrieden ist kreuzt man beim nächsten
Mal wieder an und wenn man nicht
zufrieden ist macht man was anderes
tatsächlich funktionieren Demokratien
aber nur dann dauerhaft wenn diejenigen
die hier als Konsumenten beschrieben
werden tatsächlich
urteilsfähige Bürger sind und das ist
etwas ganz anderes das heißt wenn ich
sage wir haben uns ein bisschen bequem
gemacht in der Demokratie dann haben wir
nicht darüber nachgedacht was eigentlich
die Voraussetzungen einer Demokratie
sind nämlich eine jedenfalls in der
Mehrheit kluge urteilsfähige
nicht auf Parolen abfahrende Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung nicht und da konnte man
schon in einem Umgang mit Pandemie so
seine Zweifel bekommen
das sind Voraussetzungen und da muss
mehr
Engagement hineingesteckt werden es geht
ja um die Verteidigung der Demokratie
wer ist da in erster Linie zuständig die
politische Führung die Zivilgesellschaft
beide zusammen
auf jeden Fall beide zusammen der
politische Führung muss natürlich sehr
viel mehr auch erklären warum sie das
macht jenes macht und eine der
verhängnisvollen Äußerungen war dann die
Formel der Alternativlosigkeit nicht
weil er Kurzform dafür eigentlich ich
habe alle Möglichkeiten durch
geprüft und bin zu dem Ergebnis gekommen
dass dies die günstigste ist nicht aber
dafür den Begriff alternativlos zu
verwenden ist eine Verkürzung gibt alle
möglichen Alternativen es gibt auch die
Möglichkeit immer sozusagen das
Scheiterns der Demokratie
das ist die Sache der Führung und die
Sache der Zivilgesellschaft ist sich
mehr Kompetenz im Umgang mit politischen
Fragen also verschaffen und weniger aus
dem Bauch heraus zu agieren und da kann
man drüber nachdenken wie man das macht
nicht die Schweizer haben dafür sein den
Zwang immer wieder mit Volksabstimmungen
und entscheiden die Leute zu nötigen
gewissermaßen sich mit einem Problem und
sei es nur ob da ein Haus gebaut wird
oder nicht zu beschäftigen man kann auch
sein das geht auch anders
aber darüber muss man noch mal
nachdenken Demokratie ist eine
ausgesprochen anspruchsvolle Form der
politischen Ordnung die eigentlich es
nicht zulässt dass man sagt ne das soll
mal der Scholz machen
soweit 30 Minuten geballte Ladung
herfelt Münkler herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch bei Phoenix persönlich
[Musik]